foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
Baseball Insider MLB Network Sports
Illustrated senior writer trade deadline
underway until Tuesday Tom joining us on
the program you uh reported that shohei
Otani no longer on the trading block was
he really on the trade block
uh theoretically yes which means they
weren't shopping ohtani but if you're a
general manager in this game you're
getting close to the deadline at the
time the Angels were a little bit under
500. you'd be derelicting your duties
not to pick up the phone and at least
make the call so yes calls were made
they asked about a Tony some names were
thrown around they were all minor league
prospects really no traction no momentum
but yes there was some discussion about
ohtani but really nothing to speak of in
terms of anything uh getting any
traction what kind of risk is Artie
Moreno and the angels running here
I actually think his bigger risk than
was trading Otani and really turning off
his fan base remember he had more than
three billion dollars on the table the
off season to sell the angels and he had
seller's remorse why because it sounds
corny but he loves baseball he loves
sitting on the in the owner's box and
watching games and spring training the
regular season that he wanted to make
another run for it he's always been in
love with star players you can fall in
for not developing Farm systems in depth
on the roster but he loves star players
and he had a team that was in this case
they won six to seven over 500 at the
time four games out of the Wild Card
they're in the race and for him to pull
the plug on the season was a bigger risk
so the idea that the Angels would get
quote unquote nothing for ohtani if he
go leaves as a free agent that's
ridiculous they have the best player in
baseball most attractive player in terms
of fan interest and he's having what
could be a historic season and you still
have a shot at the post seated you can't
give up that up and that's not nothing
yeah but I just wonder there's other
teams that are going to have far more
money than the angels and Artie Moreno
do and then you do run the risk of not
getting anything from him in the off
season uh the likelihood of finding
somebody who's going to bid more than
already Moreno is what in your opinion
it's likely I don't think the angels are
going to be the high bidder but I'll
tell you this if they traded him they
have zero shot of keeping him their only
way of keeping him is he sees this team
has turned a corner they're actually
competitive maybe they actually get into
the postseason
um the pickup of Lucas giolito puts the
Angels over the luxury tax limit for
only the second time that Moreno is on
the team so there's signaling here that
we've got a pretty good team we're
making a run for it we're all in that's
all good ohtani wants to win uh you have
the power of incumbency and the minute
you trade him you lose that now in an
auction atmosphere do I think the angels
will bid more than the Dodgers no I
think the Dodgers are going to offer
ohtani everything that he wants which is
the most money uh Southern California
great weather to do his two-way thing
which is super important for a guy who's
very very routine oriented like a lot of
great players but especially so for
shohei
um and he doesn't want to be like that
lead star guy AI that you know listen he
does everything on his own with the
Angel's dad you know he's on his own
program because there's nobody like him
there's no script to follow uh media
obligations he does only what he wants
to do and he's in a very comfortable
spot so I think the angels have a shot
of keeping him but I do not expect
there'll be the high bidder no I wonder
if the shohei uttani effect will be felt
maybe 15 years down the road where we
look back and say look at all of these
two-way players that he that can is he
gonna hatch like this subculture of guys
who want to do exactly what he's doing
at this level
he will hatch the idea that teams now
will consider it okay but you will not
see another otanic he is so good at
doing both disciplines the hitting and
the pitching
um he really is the Unicorn so there
there will not be certainly a flood of
autonomies there'll never be another
autonomy you may have some guys who are
talented enough that when they're in the
Minor League season teams will keep
their options open on whether the guy is
a pitcher or a hitter and if he's
talented enough maybe they do at the big
league level but I'll go back when he
was in high school dad the Dodgers
everybody thought he was going to sign
with the Dodgers in high school and
actually it was the manager of the
fighters over in Japan who said listen
if you sign with the US team they will
pigeonhole you as a pitcher or a hitter
if you sign with us you can take a path
nobody else has taken before and that's
to be a two-way player let me think
about that That Changed History wait was
that true though that the Dodgers were
going to say we want you as either a
pitcher or hitter no I think the message
was it's the way the major leagues
operate they're really not open to the
idea of doing both I think the
signotanian high school you say hey
whatever you want dude we're gonna give
it to you
um any other Nolan Arenado to the
Dodgers uh that front burner back burner
uh that's that's got something to it
then there's some legs here it's a great
fit because the Cardinals have Nolan
Gorman whose best position is third base
he can slide over there he's not Arenado
but young player what a breakout year
this year much more suited for third
base Arenado as you know from Southern
California would love to play for the
Dodgers he's got a no trade it's not a
problem for him to drop that it's a
four-year contract with just 92 million
dollars left on that so there's still
plenty of room to get shohei Otani as a
free agent Third Base has been a problem
for them defensively this year Max much
he's been a problem at third base I
think this makes a lot of sense the
Dodgers are just absolutely rich with
guys pitchers who have swing and missed
stuff that's exactly what the Cardinals
need now this could get even bigger
you're talking about maybe the Dodgers
wanting Jordan Montgomery or Jack
Flaherty uh Flaherty being another La
guy coming home you could have Chris
Taylor or Max Muncie going to St Louis
as part of this deal it could be along
the lines of that Scherzer trade Turner
deal the Dodgers made a couple of years
ago where it turns out to be a true
Blockbuster I know you're busy over the
next couple of days always great to
catch up with you Tom thanks for joining
us yeah always fun Dan thank you Tom
berducci MLB Insider also works for uh
Sports illustrator it's a senior writer
couple of phone calls in here